I can tell you how Martin Scorcese gives
me as an actor his notes after he sees
the scene he watches in a black box
watches the monitor blind is about not
really but he's come out of his box and
he's rather bright so he's guided by his
assistant
he's led across a massive cables and
hazards and he stands in front of me and
he says do you wanna do another one
simple as that it's pure and simple as
that instead of boring you to sleep with
endless notes that are unplayable that
some arrogant directors force on the
actor do you want to do another one
I say yeah or if I say no he says great
let's move on Gandhi Richard
Attenborough invited me to have lunch
with him but the extraordinary
coincidences that I was reading an
illustrated biography of Mahatma Gandhi
the week he invited me to his house so I
was looking at photographs of this
beautiful great man
and then Attenborough called me ins and
invited me to consider playing him I
remember saying to Richard Lord
Attenborough he died us bless him I'm
reading the biography of Mahatma Gandhi
while we're talking and he said of
course you are he was surrounded by
sublime coincidences I remember
Attenborough invited me to watch some
newsreel footage of him and there's he's
very well documented recordings
photographs unusual footage because it
was an iconic character and I watched
five hours of newsreel footage at one
sitting decided that it was impossible
left the cinema and and didn't look at
any more footage ever again but
Attenborough made it made the impossible
possible it was like standing at the
foothills of the largest ice-covered
mountain you've ever seen thinking I'll
go up one foot and slide down five but
he caught me through it
I will fast as a penance on
my part in arousing such emotions and I
will not stop until they stop I think
that the the the the coincidence of
loving him deeply as a man to portray
did empower me through those long
demanding days in India and the people
of India were enormous ly generous you
see there was no CGI can he believe that
that is four hundred thousand people as
his funeral
that felt extraordinary to me twenty
years in the preparation and then like a
like a bolt out of a catapult he let go
bang and he hit the target I think
modestly I think he really hit the
target beautiful film that was the
Golden Door into the film industry for
me Schindler's List oh there's a
beautiful story about Schindler's List
in and Schindler's Ark as you rightly
call it I was working with Steve
Zaillian who wrote a beautiful film
called searching for bobby fisher' we
had a scene where i was mixed in amongst
great middle european chess players and
one of the chess players in the scene
had this rather warm paperback book in
his hands and he handed it to me and if
I may he had a lovely middle European
accent is I want you to read this and he
handed it to me as if it was some holy
relic it was beautiful
so I I took the book and it was called
she endures arc and I turned the pages
and was utterly utterly hypnotized by
the book and three days later Steven
Zaillian said to me I want you to read
this and handed me Schindler's List
directed by Steven Spielberg so again I
was fatalistically a tiny step ahead of
the game sometimes happens in life it's
quite beautiful
the list is life
all around its margins my stucco I
remember meeting Steven Spielberg and we
discussed the possibility of me playing
the role I had already played Simon
Wiesenthal the great Nazi hunter in a
series and I knew that to enter the
Holocaust and end of that story
demanded a massive amount of integrity
humidity and energy and I said to Steven
Steven what you want what is my
narrative function in this film I knew
my answer and he said conscience and I
said witness and we shook hands and I
was on board it was almost the same word
I'm Man 3 the head of Marvel Kevin Kevin
fight came to see me at my house and he
explained the the twist to me
[Music]
I found it absolutely thrilling
to play an actor playing a performance
thrilling just a role the Mandarin see
it's not real I did base him on some of
the actors I rubbed shoulders with
within the Royal Shakespeare Company
it is his finest hour it is his greatest
performance I think in all humility I
must say that the Trevor is quite enough
quite a splendid actor well a panic but
then I handled it
Bugsy I think of my Lansky and I think
of him coming from an embattled shtetl
in Russia the Jews of Russia were
constantly harassed pogroms and then
followed of course by eins at scorpan in
World War two but Lansky left Russia
quite young came to America so I always
had in him the exiled Russian Jew who
knew how to look after his own because
in their settles in the Jewish villages
in Russia you had to look after your own
and you had to know how to wheel and
deal you had to know in order to survive
where to get you meet your bread where
to get your gasoline where to get safety
where to get weaponry you knew how to
work your community that was translated
by Maya Lansky into looking after his
team so I did not play him as a gangster
I played him as a patriarch
only one problem the same problem he
senses who all kids together sticking up
crap games in the streets he doesn't
respect money I worked with a wonderful
dialect coach and and also had occasion
to to watch a little bit of him on
newsreel when he was older than I played
him and I'll never forget this somebody
said hey Maya how you're doing and he
stopped on the pavement and said just
what you see that's one of my favorite
answers when people say how are you I
say just what you see sexy beast
I was dubbed as bipolar because people
could not believe that the same person
could play Mahatma Gandhi and Don Logan
[Applause]
beautiful writing great director and a
wonderful cast to work with being a
great lover of Shakespeare and having
played a fellow but not Iago I did see
that Don Logan was definitely Iago his
cry his scream was I love you why don't
you love me another cry from the script
is I don't want you to be happy why
should I so my approach to him in all
humility and compassion was that Don was
an abused child unhealed who would go on
to scream for the rest of his adult life
therefore I had a compassionate link
with him and understood his capacity for
revenge and violence against a fate that
had abused him as a child so I got quite
fond of Don being a parent I love to
observe baby steps but the first time a
child stands up on walks is a beautiful
moment not in any disrespectful way
Jonathan Glazer was taking his first
steps as a feature film director and
that can be exhilarating company because
they have no rulebook nothing is a copy
of a copy of a
oh I've done this before it works no
freshly discovering every syllable and
every gesture with you beautiful Jungle
Book
I love John's approach to the original
jungle book story and their original
trilogy of books and I think that the
that he was brave to face the darker
side of the movie and the story it's a
story about heroic orphan really
beautiful when I am doing a voiceover
and recording an animated feature
everything has to come through the voice
and and your body is is taken care of by
a set of animators so my physical
language is completely irrelevant to the
film although as I'm doing now talking
my body does come into play naturally
but any amount of this will not
compensate for what's going on on the
screen it has to be through the voice I
realize you weren't born a wolf but
could you at least act like one so you
need to be schooled or or learner door
have the great privilege of having to
having worked with great directors it
with the Royal Shakespeare Company and
great voice teachers voice coaches and
use all those skills for these wonderful
wonderful creatures perpetual grace
limited my characters pastor Byron Brown
he's a predatory creature wolf fur
leopard tiger highly cunning we'll we'll
have moments of enormous stillness
before leaping upon his prey in the
guise of being a pastor a priest milked
people of their family fortunes I have
to say that Bruce and Steve have come up
with a beautiful ten hour epic film
which will be episodically divided into
ten episodes but it's the ten hour movie
and it's absolutely beautifully written
its original it is not a copy of a copy
of a copy it's brand new astonishing and
thrilling to to breathe life into their
language and their gestures how's it
sounding
I know what one's not supposed to have
favorites so I won't say anything but
working again with the first time
director was thrilling and again he was
a great patriarch I loved playing
brave fearless tribal father figures I
find it empowering and unnecessary as a
storage to tell people and I found him
absolutely heroic capable of feats of
great endurance great resilience and
crushing grief and finally taking his
own life
Jennifer was a wonderful colleague to
work with our scenes were like like a
duet
it was beautiful working with her she
made herself very vulnerable we all did
we had to be vulnerable to the bigger
picture the greater story very pure very
beautiful story it's a story about
aspiration achieving your goal and then
suffering terrible loss suffer Island
that was my first experience with Marty
and he had a very fine grasp on exactly
where we were in the picture because
it's a story within a story within a
story and at first you think possibly
one could construe my character as a
rather dark sinister force and then you
realize as my character evolves that he
actually as a as a psychiatrist embodies
unconditional love that he would do
anything to save and cure that patient
even if it meant going into hell with
him and guiding him through hell and out
again then blast away because that's the
only way you're ever getting off this
island
Andrew please don't
Leo's character decides that he's having
the symptoms of the recurring nightmare
yet again and decides to have himself
lobotomized which is a kind of suicide
so again we're dealing with very pure
archetypal characters they're not copies
of a copy of a copy of a copy they're
utterly original and thrilling and I
believe it was one of Marty's most
successful films of the box office and
it was a joy to be with him Hugo to play
a director directed by a great director
was challenging and thrilling and
exhilarating and I was very honored that
he chosen me to play one of clearly his
great heroes of cinema as you know he's
passionate about saving every fragment
of motion-picture footage that's
available on the face of the earth he
restores this fading corroding image of
our beautiful industry and past and
craft again it's a pure piece of
mythology where my character Josh has
his years in the wilderness rather like
a biblical character nothing would have
pitted us merge into broken wind-up toy
and then after years in the wilderness
rather like the tablets from heaven his
films are rediscovered placed back into
his hands screened again to great
applause and he ended his days I think
as a very grateful and and happy man and
the story again rather like a patriarch
the story of him guiding the little boy
through life and the boy guiding him
which is beautiful is another wonderful
layer that scores a
he in his depth of imagination is aware
of I am standing before you tonight
because of one very brave young man I
think that if I can see on the page that
the writer director has a genuine grasp
of patterns of human behavior and I can
recognize ah that's a real dance then
I'm on board if again I'm sorry to use
this phrase but it haunts me a bit if
it's a copy of a copy of a copy I can
smell it immediately I'm not interested
originality purity and something that
has its roots in something eternal